je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
connaissent un peu les méthodes de
fabrication des brasseurs espèrent
pas d'experts mais des passionnés
quelques curieux sont venus découvrir
les coulisses de la petite sœur
installée à Sartrouville en 2015 cette
brasserie propose des bières de
producteurs locaux mais aussi de la
fabrication maison au programme
présentation des ingrédients de la
couleur de la bière ou encore du
matériel de fabrication certains sont
surpris que parfois on peut mettre en
effet deux mois pour fabriquer une bière
ils sont surpris qu'il allait sortir des
fermenteurs la bière est sans bulle qui
est nos refermentations naturelles en
bouteille la personne est très dynamique
elle présente l'ensemble de des bières
bon c'est un monde inconnu mais j'ai
trouvé ça un passionnant étape
importante le brassage des ingrédients
se fait en une journée dans ces grosses
cuves de 1000 litres les enzymes
transforment l'amidon présent dans les
céréales en sucre simple c'est là on va
mettre à peu près 200 250 kg de Malte en
sachant que plus on est de Malte plus on
aura une bière alcoolisée à la fin
on va mettre de l'eau chaude on va dire
entre 60 70 degrés et vous avez cette
pale qui va mélanger le tout alors le
projet qui est fabriqué de la bière mais
aussi le partager partager la
fabrication de bière partager le fait de
produire localement quelque chose bien
ou bloguer note de réglisse d'agrumes ou
de banane point d'orgue de ce voyage
sensoriel une dégustation pour découvrir
les différents arômes de cette
production maison très très douce pas
d'amertume et un petit goût de pain
chaud de céréales ou de miel et ça ça
passe vachement la moyenne à deux sur
les trois que j'ai bien aimé la salle de
style irlandais et puis la session IP
vas-y 60 000 bouteilles de bière
estampillé la petite sœur son produit de
surplace chaque année si vous aussi vous
souhaitez découvrir les secrets de
fabrication des visites gratuites sont
organisées les samedis à 15 heures dans
les coulisses de la brasserie
[Musique]